[Music]  and who madam their roles really involve  certain hardships they really had to be  extremely thin and they had to eat very  very little during the shooting we had a  nutritionist with us but it was a  physical hardship it was great working  with Andrew because we were starving  together one of my favorite moments was  we were on a boat and they had the front  of the boat tied to a big rope that they  pushed out into the water and the entire  crew and cast and extras are all on the  shore and they called the lunch break  well I go now that's fine we'll just  stay out here in the boat so we had like  a panoramic view of everybody eating on  the shore you know like passing around  dumplings and all these like noodles you  know like turning away food being like  oh no I'm done and you could still see  food that are left on the plate that was  one of my favorite moments it creates a  great deal of appreciation for all the  things that you've taken for granted  previously  [Music]